I think you know across the board
there's gonna be some things that are
maintained I'm always gonna be positive
still and even if I do do comedy it
won't be at anyone's expense because it
will be on everyone's expense so I'm a
big fan of I'm in front of everyone
including myself that way we're all
being made fun of together it's still
gonna be good vibes I still want to be
inspirational I'm motivating where I can
I still want to bring my point of view
it will be a little more aged up than
what I've done on YouTube so I think in
how I'm telling stories might be a
little different but the sentiment will
still be the same I'm still myself in my
vlogs on my YouTube videos and here I'm
still myself you're just seeing Lily on
different platforms oh that's right with
Lily taking over Carson Daly's time slot
she's leaving her mark in the
male-dominated genre as the first female
of colour to host a late-night show on
network television
amongst the likes of Jimmy Kimmel James
Corden Jimmy Fallon Stephen Colbert and
Seth Meyers
but when was the moment that you were
like you know what this is if I can do
this is I know I can do Wow when NBC
first approached me I'm not gonna lie
first I was like oh wait can I do this
like is this in my wheelhouse
and I was a little uncertain I spoke to
some of my friends got some advice
really sat on it meditated on for a
second and when I decided that no I'm
going to do this it was zero to 100 once
I decided there wasn't a part of me that
was like you can't do this I was like
we're doing it and now we're committed
and now we're gonna do it I am so
excited to finally tell you about
something I have been working on since
literally forever and that is that your
girl is getting your own we're watching
you show yeah and it looks like you've
been doing this for you know like 100
years back we know that you're used to
being on camera obviously yep but this
is different that's different it is
different I mean I do pride myself in my
ability to not seem nervous because I
definitely am I'm super nervous before I
walk out so she's a little different I'm
used to a live audience of course the
music being on camera
but this is like a formatted timed
scheduled thing works like I have to hit
certain beats there's just certain
transitions that have to happen so it's
definitely out of my comfort zone but I
mean all great things lie
your discomfort zone right if I enter do
I want home based on the left home base
in the middle
another left version another left
version what's different between people
working on my show will tell you I'm
involved in every aspect of it yeah some
like how that thing opens and closes to
how things are shown on the teleprompter
to what's on my desk to like just every
aspect is like why would you come in
here and do this your way
right well the reason you wouldn't is
because it's hiring a sec but I have
embraced that you know I've embraced
what this journey is going to be and so
I want to make sure that my stamp is on
everything I'm really honest with you
when I saw the schedule I was like oh
this is a vacation like I said at least
it's a regimented prior to this I'd be
working and then traveling and
everything was all over the place so the
workload is not scary to me if I'm
really really honest I'm sure it gets
tiring but I'm used to that I'm very
used prior to this I was doing
everything myself or with very few
people there was like a hundred people
working on this show if there's any
little task that needs to happen there's
someone for that task it's like every
day someone comes up to me they go hi
I'm the script like highlighter I
highlight the script like that's a job
right just highlight the scribble it
gets incredible little nod isn't our and
I keep doing the notes on the shape of
it one big thing I notice obviously is
on your set
I wanted the skyline to be pretty vague
I didn't want anyone to be like that's
New York that's LA but I did want to
make a nod to Toronto so although the
rest of the buildings are not a specific
place that is a nod to the CN Tower
because those are my roots and you're
right there's a lot of people that watch
somehow we have no idea what that is
but I know what it is and it's purposely
placed right behind my chair because
that's that's my home and that's where I
learned all the things I talked about
you know my point of view as a person is
so so much because of Toronto with so
much because of the diversity the types
of music that plays to the audience in
between types of jokes I'm making
they're all born and raised in Toronto
being that you are like a keen observer
in society yeah so anything that you
noticed being out here that you didn't
expect to be so different from what
things were like back home yes there is
one thing so in Toronto I could not name
a single and this is not an exaggeration
I could literally not name a single
person whose parents were born in Canada
not a single yeah and when I moved to LA
I was shocked
I wouldn't ask for where your parents
from and they were like Ohio and I'm
like what there's so many more
immigrants in my life or second
generation immigrants in my life
when I was in Toronto where people knew
languages then used more some food and
music where it's not as diverse yeah
it's not wrong or right it's just I
almost felt a little a little out of
place if I'm being really candid when I
first moved here I wasn't able to really
relate to my friends talking about them
moving out of their houses when they
were 15 and living with their boyfriends
all the stories they had I was like oh I
could not relate to this because I just
grew up in a different culture and I was
surrounded by people from different
cultures and so that was a little bit I
never thought I'd have a culture shock
moving from Canada burger but there
definitely was one the idea of pushing
South Asian culture award you guys
mention that yeah I want to know what
that means to you here in this space
something I can do with that
I mean first and foremost it is existing
in this space I think that but on its
own me existing even if I came out and
did a model that nothing to do with
Indian culture or parents or whatever it
would still be doing something because
inevitably my point of view is embedded
into everything I'm saying and and and
how I look on screen is already a win in
my opinion I think it's so important
that my show is gonna is gonna represent
the world and that's how it should be
you know storytelling is about people
relating to you or hearing a point of
view they otherwise have not heard
that's what it's supposed to be
[Music]
[Music]